[Música]
Bienvenidos a Francia en foco encontrar
un médico las últimas semanas en Francia
ha sido todo un desafío están en huelga
piden que se aumente el precio de la
consulta de 25 a 50 euros una tarifa que
fija el seguro de enfermedad un ente
público sin embargo esta crisis está
motivada por muchas otras demandas todo
un desafío para el gobierno de Manuel
macron y su ministerio de salud
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el nuevo plan de salud que fue votado al
regreso de vacaciones que debe durar
cinco años sentencia la muerte de la
medicina liberal o independiente quiere
que los pacientes en un futuro cercano
sean sanados sin médicos pues la
medicina liberal se ocupa del 90% de los
pacientes y hoy el proyecto prevé que
esos cuidados sean ejecutados por un
farmacéutico es decir medicina de
mostrador hecha por gente que no estudio
es una profesión que es cada vez más
difícil con una población cada vez más
numerosa la gente pide más cuidados la
población envejece es difícil hoy curar
a todo el mundo la carga de trabajo es
enorme y es verdad hoy muchos médicos
están en dificultad
un servicio de urgencia hace 25 años
comenzamos con 6.000 pacientes por año y
hoy tenemos a 36.000 los jóvenes médicos
se van porque es muy duro y prefieren
trabajar en otra cosa como en trabajos
divertidos y la gente que se queda no
quiere trabajar porque es peligroso el
otro día yo estaba un poco débil con
traje una virosis me caí al final de las
24 horas a las 5 de la mañana y las
enfermeras me encontraron tendido en el
suelo porque no podía más
en Francia hay más de 120.000 médicos
liberales Francia enfocó acompañó a uno
de ellos para saber cómo es el día a día
de un profesional de salud independiente
es aún de noche cuando Antoine llega a
su consulta
son las siete y veinticinco ya dejé los
niños en la guardería y comienza una
nueva jornada de trabajo
Antón Tiene 38 años hace nueve que
trabaja como médico general después de
realizar diez años de estudios es la
segunda vez que se suma una huelga de
médicos desde que comenzó su carrera
creo que efectivamente si no se hace más
atractiva nuestra actividad No seremos
suficientes para administrar todo esto
nosotros estamos listos para trabajar
pero no a cualquier precio ni bajo
cualquier condición lo que queremos es
tener tiempo con nuestros pacientes y
que ese tiempo sea remunerado
una revalorización de la consulta
indispensable según los médicos
generales para que los jóvenes quieran
estudiar medicina hoy una consulta donde
un galeno independiente cuesta 25 euros
pero los jueguistas quieren que la
tarifa aumente a 50 para poder contratar
personal y dar más tiempo a los
pacientes
hago un mail para un cardiólogo y luego
Busco una dirección de cardiología
porque también hay cada vez menos
cardiólogos
esta carta actúan la escribe delante del
paciente pero también están los otros
mails que recibe durante todo el día Y
que debe tratar fuera del horario de
consulta
es un verdadero trabajo en la sombra hay
muchas cosas que debemos tratar
paralelamente exámenes que son
catastróficos y frente a los que hay que
hacer algo rápidamente Hay que llamar al
paciente solicitar una ambulancia muchas
veces
desde los recién nacidos hasta las
mujeres embarazadas pasando por los
adolescentes y los ancianos las
consultas encadenan y no se parecen
entre ellas una diversidad que hace la
riqueza de su trabajo pero también exige
un gran compromiso personal
parantones imprescindible poder discutir
con sus colegas
En su centro médico hay otros cuatro
galenos una presencia que él considera
indispensable
yo no podría pensar en un ejercicio solo
en mi Rincón algunos lo consiguen pero
yo creo que necesitamos escucharnos
entre nosotros y discutir y hablar de
otras cosas no solo la medicina hablar
de fútbol por ejemplo sobre el mundial
pero durante la pausa del almuerzo No
hay tiempo para hablar de fútbol
son las 12:48 del mediodía acabamos de
hacer una quincena de consultas en la
oficina y hemos partido a tres visitas a
domicilio
dos días por semana antonas estas
visitas a domicilio para ver a sus
pacientes que no pueden llegar a su
consulta
no puedo ir mira mi pie me amputaron el
dedo
un trabajo fundamental para mantener el
vínculo con esos pacientes que pierden
su autonomía a causa de un problema de
salud y que necesita
el costo de Esta visita que dura un poco
más de media hora es de 35 euros 10 más
que el precio de una consulta en su
despacho
visitas que cada vez menos médicos
realizan por falta de tiempo hoy antoian
Atendió 35 pacientes desde los 10 días
de vida hasta los 96 años
como alternativa algunos profesionales
han decidido unirse y fundar casas
médicas y así mutualizar gastos veamos
para no llegar hasta el bernaut muchos
médicos eligen ejercer en casas médicas
como aquí en montjuïc en las afueras de
París
una de las más grandes casas de salud de
Francia acaba de abrir
son 3600 metros cuadrados donde ejercen
unos 50 médicos liberales o
independientes
Aunque la ciudad de 100.000 habitantes
está pegada a la capital es un desierto
médico con 4,6 médicos por cada 10.000
habitantes
quisimos crear una estructura donde
tuviéramos todas las especialidades
médicas además de material técnico
completo para poder tener una
estimulación intelectual y una
trayectoria de ocupaciones interesantes
para los médicos
y pese a la escasez de profesionales de
la salud el centro no tuvo problemas
para contratar
logramos contratar gente más bien joven
recién egresados que hacían reemplazos
en distintos lugares y que no habían
encontrado todavía una estructura para
instalarse
a esta doctora la trajo la posibilidad
de continuar con un médico general pero
con el apoyo de una estructura de este
tipo que cuenta con personal que se
ocupa de las tareas administrativas
es muy maravilloso tener alguien en el
día a día que nos ayuda y nos libera de
las tareas administrativas que son cada
vez más numerosas eso nos permite
destinar más tiempo clínico a los
pacientes
no hay sobrecarga administrativa y en
cambio Si hay colegas a quienes pedir un
consejo
estas condiciones de trabajo benefician
también a los pacientes en dos horas
maxim veo dos médicos y sin esperar pudo
pasar una radiografía a los pulmones
afortunadamente la radiografía es normal
dos centros como este deben abrir este
año en París y otro en la periferia pero
se necesitan distintas soluciones para
devolver la Esperanza a Los
profesionales sobre todo aquellos que
comienzan la tasa de suicidio de los
médicos en prácticas es tres veces
superior a la de otros jóvenes de su
edad
Pero dónde está la raíz de esta crisis
nos lo explica nuestro invitado del día
el profesor Frederick villac él es
economista especialista en temas de
protección social y creador del
instituto de la salud
Freddy que empecemos por algo muy simple
los médicos liberales piden aumentar el
precio de la consulta de 25 euros a 50
euros que lo que hay detrás Qué
significa realmente este aumento de 25
euros en esa tarifa
es una llamada de alerta a los jóvenes
médicos hay que saber que estamos en una
fase de negociación de convenio con el
seguro de enfermedad que es la rama de
salud de la seguridad social y están
discutiendo de aquí a fines de marzo las
condiciones de tarifa que van a ser
aplicadas los próximos cinco años
hoy el modelo económico de los médicos
liberales o generalistas consiste en
hacer el máximo de consultas muy mal
pagadas porque 25 euros es de la tarifa
más baja de Europa
Entonces el tiempo de consulta no ha
cesado de reducirse de algunos minutos y
el médico tenga que atender en gran
cantidad de pacientes y la nueva
generación no acepta eso pues quiere
hacer buena medicina una medicina de
calidad que necesita de tiempo de medios
y de una remuneración correcta
ellos también se quejan de la burocracia
no es solo una demanda de los médicos
liberales sino que también de otros
profesionales de la salud de que hay
excesivo papeleo Y eso también a ellos
les implica pagar alguien que se ocupe
si quieren tener más tiempo con los
pacientes
desde hace 25 años hay un movimiento
hacia una estabilización del sistema de
salud y eso que nuestro sistema era
relativamente descentralizado y dejaba
mucha autonomía de los actores ya sea en
el hospital o en las consultas
particulares o médicos de ciudad pero el
estado ha estado pensando en manejar
mejor los gastos decidió administrarte
nuevo todo eso y desarrolló una
administración muy importante que da el
sentimiento a la totalidad de los
médicos del sistema público y también a
los independientes de pérdida de sentido
de trabajo
hasta ahora Francia era muy orgullosa de
tener uno de los mejores sistemas de
salud del mundo pero hemos visto que las
crisis se han ido sucediendo después del
coi 19 la crisis del hospital público la
crisis de las urgencias y ahora los
médicos liberales
Es verdad que Francia creó uno de los
mejores sistemas de Cuidado fuimos de
los mejores del mundo para medicalizar
los territorios sin embargo como en
todos los países desarrollados la
población ha envejecido y las
enfermedades se han vuelto crónicas Y
eso obliga a cambiar la estrategia de
una centrada en lo curativo o una
centrada en la prevención de la
enfermedad lo más temprano para intentar
maximizar la probabilidad de que las
personas tengan buena salud el máximo
tiempo posible y retrasar la llegada de
las enfermedades
Muchas gracias Frederick Villa por esta
entrevista
tras la última manifestación de los
médicos liberales el presidente Manuel
macron hizo una serie de anuncios desde
un hospital público sin embargo por
ahora sus promesas no han calmado la
cólera de los galenos hasta aquí este
capítulo de Francia enfoco Muchas
gracias por habernos acompañado y hasta
una próxima por las pantallas de France
24 o en France 24.com
[Música]